Transcriber: Bilge Yilmaz
Gözden geçirme: Erman Turkmen
Selçuk Şirin
Sayıları Konuşturan Yazar
Şimdi Türkiye’ye dair,
işim gereği elimden her gün
yüzlerce veri geçiyor.
Eğitimden istihdama,
ekonomiden iş güvenliğine,
Türkiye’nin bir fotoğrafını
çektiğimiz zaman
genel olarak benim
söyleyeceğim yorum şu:
Durum pek iç açıcı değil.
Fakat bu beni hiçbir zaman
umutsuzluğa itmiyor.
Çünkü bu topraklarda, bu coğrafyada,
umutsuz olma şansımız yok.
Tarihimize baktığımızda,
ister yakın, ister uzak tarihe bakın
bu topraklar en zor koşullarda bile
kendi içerisinden bir çare çıkartmış.
Fakat bir veri var ki,
bu beni son derece endişelendiriyor.
O veri de şu arkadaşlar.
Yakın bir zamanda yayınlandı
ve benim kaygılarımı biraz daha arttırdı.
Türkiye'de biz hayal kurmayı bilmiyoruz.
Çocukların yarısı hayal kurmuyor.
Bu Intel’in yaptığı, birkaç hafta önce
açıklanan bir araştırma.
Yetişkinlerin de yalnızca
%14'ü hayal kuruyor.
Peki bu çocuklar ne hayali kuruyor diye
biraz baktığınız zaman
hayallerin büyük bir kısmı
ev sahibi olmak, inşaat,
iş sahibi olmak, öğretmenlik, polislik.
Bunları geçince
büyük hayaller maalesef yok.
Beni bu son derece kaygılandırıyor.
Çünkü hayal olmadan, büyük hayaller
kurmadan, bizim gelişmemiz,
kalkınmamız, şuradan şuraya gitmemiz,
ilerlememiz mümkün değil.
Hem teknolojik olarak, hem beşeri olarak,
hem toplum olarak, hem birey olarak.
Bunu ben nereden biliyorum?
Bunu ben kendi bireysel
hikâyemden de biliyorum.
Bu gördüğünüz benim ilkokul fotoğrafım.
Köyde pek çoğunuzun,
ya kendiniz ya anne babanızda
benzer hikâyeler,
benzer fotoğraflar vardır.
Bir köyde ben doğdum.
İlkokulu orada okudum.
Benim liseyi bitirdiğim ilçe ya da il
Türkiye’nin üniversite sınavlarında
her sene en başarısız olan ili.
Çok istikrarlı bir şekilde.
Benim mezun olduğum lise,
o ilin en başarısız lisesi.
Ben o liseden ikmale kalarak mezun oldum.
Peki nasıl oldu da ODTÜ'yü
direkt o liseden kazandım?
Nasıl oldu da New York Üniversitesi'nin
en genç kürsü profesörlerinden biri oldum?
Muhtemelen hemen kafanızda
bir fotoğraf canlandı.
İşte hoca tesadüfen köye doğmuş bir dâhi.
İlgisi yok.
Bunun tek bir sebebi var,
o da şu an en önde oturuyor.
Babamla annem, buradalar bu arada.
(Alkış)
Bunun tek bir sebebi var.
Oldukça karamsar veriler paylaşacağım,
tek alkış bu olabilir arkadaşlar.
Bunun tek bir sebebi var.
Ortaokul 3. sınıftayken babam geldi,
bana bir fotoğraf gösterdi.
Bir öğrencisinin mezuniyet fotoğrafı.
Bu fotoğrafta ben Ortadoğu Teknik
Üniversitesi’nin mezunlarını gördüm.
Çok güzel, şık elbiseler giyinmişler.
Arkada bir stad var,
orada güzel bir yazı var.
Ben o fotoğrafı gördüm,
bak şimdi bile ürperdim.
Dedim ki ''Burada, şu fotoğrafta
ben de olmak isterim.''
Orada bir hayal, bir tahayyül canlandı.
Yani nasıl olur da -üniversiteye
girmek istemiyorum-
Üniversite sınavına belki gitmeyecektim.
Lise 1'deyken ben köyde
bir bakkal dükkânı açtım.
Lise 2'deyken sevgilim vardı.
Orta 3'te iken çoğu arkadaşlarım
evlenmişti zaten.
Lise 3'te benim bütün hayalim:
Geleceğim köyde bakkalın başına geçeceğim.
Üniversite sınavına sırf
il merkezini görmek için gittim.
Daha önce gitmemiştim oraya.
Nasıl oldu da böyle bir çocuk
oradan çıktı, ODTÜ'ye geldi ve sonrası.
Bunun tek nedeni işte Orta 3'te
sadece hayali vermediler bana.
Sadece tahayyülü vermediler, aynı zamanda
eve büyük bir kütüphane kurdular.
Beş kardeşiz. Üç tane doktora
var evde, iki tane master var.
Şimdi buradan yola çıkarak
ben bir hikâye anlatmak istiyorum size
ama biraz karamsar bir hikâye.
Türkiye'ye dair yaklaşık 20 yıldır
yurt dışında çalışıyorum.
Son 10 yılımda neredeyse 5 yılımı
ben burada geçirdim.
Her ay gidip geliyorum New York’a.
Dün gece de zaten oradan geldim.
Şimdi en son yaptığım çalışmayı
biraz sizle paylaşmak istiyorum.
Biliyorsunuz Türkiye’nin
çok ciddi bir sorunu var.
Bizim kendi çocuklarımızla ilgili,
onları nasıl yetiştirdiğimizle ilgili
verileri paylaşacağım.
Ama son 5 yıl içerisinde
bize 3 milyon nüfus katıldı.
Bu 3 milyonun yaklaşık 2 milyonu çocuk.
Yani 18 yaşın altında.
''Bu çocuklar kimdir,
ne ihtiyaçları var,
nereye gidecekler ve biz
bu çocuklarla ne yapacağız''
soruları beni son derece düşündürüyor.
Niye düşündürüyor?
Çünkü bu olay başladığında benim
New York Üniversitesi’ndeki asistanım,
Pakistanlı doktora öğrencim geldi dedi ki:
‘’Hocam, mülteciler
gelmeye başlamış 2012’de."
‘’Aman!" dedi "Aman bunları
anlamaya çalışın."
"Çünkü biz Pakistan’a bunlar ilk gelmeye
başladıklarında hiç dert etmedik."
"Biz bir zamanlar Hindistan’la
yarışan bir ülkeydik.
Şimdi Hindistan uzaya gidiyor,
biz orta çağa geri döndük."
"Aman siz aynı hatayı yapmayın.’’
Peki bu çocuklar kim?
Bu benim araştırma ekibim.
Bizim yaptığımız araştırmada
bulduğumuz birkaç veri.
Bu çocukların %74’ü
ailesinden birini kaybetmiş.
Yani her 4 kişiden 3’ü ya yetim,
ya da bir kardeşini savaşta kaybetmiş.
Gördüğünüz resimler bizim araştırmamızda
çocukların kendi çizdiği resimler.
Bu çocukların her 3 tanesinden 1 tanesi,
yani %30’u bireysel olarak
silahlı ya da fiziki bir şiddet mağduru.
Peki bu kadar mağduriyet,
fiziki şiddet görüyor,
başına silah dayanıyor,
ailesinden birini kaybediyor.
Bu nereye gidiyor?
Bunun gittiği yer travma.
Biz buna posttravmatik
stres bozukluğu diyoruz.
Posttravmatik travma bozukluğu
yaşayan çocukların oranı %35.
Bu %35 nedir diye düşünürseniz
normal popülasyonun 10 katı.
Vietnam’dan dönen Amerikan
askerlerinden daha yüksek bir oran bu.
Bununla da kalmadık biz
aynı zamanda depresyonu ölçtük.
Bu çocukların yarısı
klinik manada depresyonda.
Yani kendisini öldürmek istiyor,
uyumak istiyor uyuyamıyor,
yemek sorunu var vesaire.
Şimdi bu kadar travma
yaşamış bir nüfus var.
2 milyon çocuktan söz ediyoruz.
Peki bu çocuklar şu an nerede?
Nerede olması lazım?
Okullarda olması lazım.
Psikolojik ihtiyaçlarını falan geçtim,
en azından bir yerde,
düzenli bir hayatın içinde olmaları lazım.
Bu çocukların %70’i, ortaokul çağındaki
çocukların %70'i okulda değil.
Sokakta.
Bir kısmını görmüşsünüzdür zaten.
Lisedekilerin %90’ı okulda değil.
İlkokuldakilerin yalnızca yarısı okulda.
Onlar da derme çatma okullar.
Şimdi karşımızda çok tehlikeli
bir alaşım var.
Travma yaşamış bir grup ve
okulda eğitim almıyorlar.
Dilini bilmedikleri bir ülkeye
yerleşmiş durumdalar.
Bunun nereye varacağını anlamak için
dünyaya bakmamız lazım.
Üç tane coğrafyaya bakın.
Uzak Asya'ya bakın.
Pakistan-Afganistan sınırı
sadece bir tanesi.
Oradaki mülteci kamplarından
Taliban çıktı.
Afrika'ya bakın, Afrika’daki mülteci
kamplarından Boko Haram çıktı.
Orta Doğu'ya bakın,
Orta Doğu'yu biliyorsunuz zaten.
Önümüzde böyle bir tehlike var.
Bizim bu çocukları kurtarmak için
yapmamız gereken tek bir şey var.
Bizim bu çocuklara daha iyi bir
yaşam umudu vermemiz lazım.
Peki bu çocuklarda bu umut,
bu potansiyel var mı?
Evet var.
Bu çizim de bu çocuklardan
topladığımız veriler.
Biz bunlara hayallerini sorduk.
Bu çocuklar hâlen daha
hayal kurabiliyorlar.
Daha iyi bir dünya, yaşanır bir dünya
hayalini kendileri için kurabiliyorlar.
Fakat bunu kurma süreleri sınırlı.
3 yıl daha, 4 yıl daha bunu kurabilirler.
Ondan sonra vazgeçiyorlar.
Ondan sonra bu çocuklar, eğer biz
onlara daha önce ulaşamazsak,
suç örgütlerinin elinde,
terör organizasyonlarının elinde,
fuhuş çetelerinin elinde,
maalesef yem olarak kalacaklar.
Böyle bir tercih yapmak zorundayız.
Biz mi erken ulaşacağız yoksa onlar mı?
Şimdi tabii bu verileri Twitter'da,
başka ortamlarda paylaşınca tepki geliyor.
''Ya hocam!'' diyorlar.
''Türkiye’nin kendi sorunları zaten var,
bu çocuklar niye geldi, bunlar
niye geldi?'' vesaire.
Buraya nasıl geldiklerinin
hiçbir önemi yok.
Şu an burada olmaları yeterli.
Politik olarak bunun pek çok sebebi var.
Tartışabiliriz, birilerini suçlayabiliriz.
Güzel ama bunların tercihi değil zaten.
O siyasi, ideolojik bir tartışma.
Burada sözünü ettiğim
gayet insani bir nokta
ama aynı zamanda güvenlikle ilgili
çok önemli bir nokta.
Şimdi bizim bu çocuklara
kendi çocuklarımızdan
daha fazla yatırım yapmak gibi
bir zorunluluğumuz var.
Bunu nasıl yapacağız derken,
doğal olarak hepiniz kendi
çocuklarınızı düşüyorsunuz.
Kendi çocuklarımız nerede?
Bu veri de beni endişelendiriyor.
PISA.
PISA sınavını pek çoğunuz
belki biliyorsunuz.
Ben yaklaşık 3-4 yıl önce PISA’yı
yaygınlaştırıp tanıtmak için çok uğraştım.
Çünkü Türkiye’deki eğitim sisteminin
nerede olduğunu anlamak için
elimizde veri yok arkadaşlar.
Standart, uluslararası
kıyaslanabilir veri yok.
Bir tek bu veri var.
Bunu da zaten Dünya Bankası
ile birlikte yapıyoruz.
Milli Eğitim Bakanlığı’nın verisi.
Bizim çocuklarımız fen bilgisinde,
matematikte ve okuduğunu anlamada
yani Türkçe'de, ana dillerinde,
dünyada ilk 40 arasında yoklar.
Biliyorsunuz Türkiye G20 ülkesi.
Biz G20 ülkesiyiz.
Nüfusumuzun yarısı 30 yaşın altında
ve çocuklarımız ilk 40'ta yok.
Çok fazla matematik bilmenize gerek yok.
İlk 20'deyiz, ekonomik büyüklük olarak
çocuklarımız ilk 40'ta yok.
Nereye gideceğiz biz?
Sadece bu değil.
Aynı zamanda bizim bir de başka
daha büyük bir sorunumuz var.
O da ekonomik durumumuz.
Kişi başına milli gelir,
son 10 yılda yerinde sayıyor.
Şu veriye baktığınız zaman
düz bir çizgi göreceksiniz.
Son 9 yılda milli gelir,
olduğu yerde sayıyor.
Buna biz ekonomi literatüründe
''Orta Gelir Tuzağı'' diyoruz.
Buradan kurtulmanın da yolu,
katma değeri yüksek ekonomiye geçiş.
Biraz teknik bir deyim.
Ben buradan kurtulmanın yolunun, hayal
ekonomisine geçiş olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Katma değeri yüksek ekonominin
diğer bir tarifi İnovasyon Ekonomisi.
İnovasyon demek de hayal düşü,
hayal gücü yüksek insanların,
beceri seviyesi yüksek
insanların üretmesi demek.
Peki buradan biz nasıl kurtulacağız?
Dünyada 3.000 Dolar'dan 10.000 Dolar'a
gelen onlarca ülke var.
Kişi başı milli gelirde.
Çünkü 3.000 Dolar'dan 10.000 Dolar'a
inşaatla, yolla gelebilirsiniz,
fındık satarak gelebilirsiniz,
ham madde ile gelebilirsiniz.
Fakat 10.000 Dolar'dan 20.000 Dolar'a
ham madde satarak gelemezsiniz.
İnşaat yaparak gelemezsiniz.
10.000 Dolar'dan
20.000 Dolar'a gelmek için
yaptığınız her işe
katma değer katmanız lazım.
Katma değer nedir?
Akıl, zekâ, fikir, tasarım, sanat.
Bütün bunları katmadan
ürettiğiniz hiçbir şey,
sizi 10.000 Dolar'dan
20.000 Dolar'a götüremez.
Pek çok örnek verebilirim.
Kitabımda da bunun değişik
pek çok örneği var.
En son Uber diye bir şey çıktı mesela.
Uber nedir?
Bir çöpçatan servisi.
Bir tarafta aracı olanlar var,
öbür tarafta taksi ihtiyacı olanlar var.
Bir yazılım yapılmış.
O yazılım aracı olanlarla, taksi ihtiyacı,
araç ihtiyacı olanları buluşturuyor.
Ortada filo yok, şoför yok. Yazılım.
Yazılım firması diyorum ben buna.
Tabii bir hayalle başlıyor bu.
Bunun kıymetini bileniniz var mı?
Piyasa değeri?
50 küsur milyar dolar.
Şimdi 50 milyar deyince
tabii anlaşılmıyor.
Ama Türk Hava Yolları,
benim Türkiye’deki para birimim.
Kaç Türk Hava Yolları eder?
10 tane Türk Hava Yolları ediyor.
Kitapta WhatsApp’ın hikâyesini anlattım.
52 tane çalışanın kurduğu
bir şirket WhatsApp.
Bu 52 çalışan WhatsApp satıldığı zaman,
-ben Hürriyet’te Pazartesileri yazıyorum-
WhatsApp satıldığı zaman
baktım kaç liraya satılmış,
kaç milyon dolara.
18 milyar Dolar.
Ya dedim bu nedir yani?
Öyle bir paramız olmadığı için
anlamıyorum fiyatını.
Dedim ki Cumhuriyet tarihi boyunca
bizim ürettiğimiz en büyük markaları,
en büyük şirketleri alt alta
bir koyup bakayım.
Beş tane en büyük Türk
şirketini alt alta koyun.
Tüpraş’ı koyun, Türk Telekom’u koyun,
Türk Hava Yolları’nı koyun,
Petrol Ofisi’ni koyun.
Alt alta koyun,
hepsi bir WhatsApp etmiyor.
Hava alanları var, uçaklar var.
Hepsini bir tarafa koyuyorsunuz,
bir WhatsApp etmiyor.
Minecraft diye bir oyun satıldı.
Minecraft satıldığında ben oturup
Türkiye’deki madenleri hesaplamadım.
Çünkü bir yıllık maden gelirimiz
Minecraft etmiyordu.
Fakat bütün bu örnekler
teknoloji olduğu için,
siz de biraz teknolojiye yakın bir grup
olduğunuz için gayet iyi anladınız.
Ben aynı hikâyeyi fındık
üzerinden de anlatıyorum.
Geçen sene bir haber yayınlandı.
''Türkiye’de fındık ihracatında
rekor kırıldı.''
Kaç lira biliyor musunuz?
3 milyar dolar.
Cumhuriyet tarihi boyunca
en yüksek ihracat yaptığımız yıl
diye kutlamalar yapıldı. Çok güzel.
Bu fındığı kim alıyor ve ne yapıyor,
bunu araştırdım.
Bu fındığı İtalya’da gökten,
gökten değil ağaçtan düşen
4 fındığın 1 tanesini
İtalya’da bir şirket alıyor.
Bu şirket alıyor,
üstüne bir marka koyuyor.
Bir yıllık satışı 10 küsur
milyar dolar bu şirketin.
Şimdi fındığı alıyoruz biz.
10 milyon kişi Türkiye’de,
çoluk çocuk Güneydoğu'dan geliyor,
zorla çalıştırıyoruz, koşullar belli.
3 milyar dolar satış yaptık,
çok güzel diyoruz.
Öbür tarafta alıyorlar,
500 tane çalışanı var.
Fakat işte buradan oraya geçmek için,
yani ham madde potansiyel coğrafyanın,
doğanın bize verdiğini satmak, onun
hamallığını yapmanın ötesine geçmek için
bizim yapısal dönüşümler yapmamız lazım.
Nedir bu?
3 tane çok basit önerim var benim.
Şimdi bakın bilgi ekonomisi diyoruz,
bilgi ekonomisi ne demek?
Bilgiye ulaşma ve
bilgiyi paylaşma ekonomisi.
Türkiye bilgi ekonomisinde
maalesef çok kötü bir noktada.
Çünkü biz bilgiye ulaşmanın
önüne engeller koyuyoruz.
Basın özgürlüğü dediğiniz şey,
bilgiye ulaşma özgürlüğüdür.
Dünyada bilgiye kolay ulaşan ülkeler
daha çok inovasyon yapıyor.
Bilgi ekonomisini yürütmek için,
başarılı olmak için inovasyon şart.
Dolayısıyla böyle bir ilişki var.
Bizim basın özgürlüğünün önündeki
bütün engelleri kaldırmamız lazım.
Eğer bunu kaldırmazsak,
''İki tane gazeteci gözaltına
alındı, bana ne!'' derseniz,
oradan inovasyon çıkmıyor.
Bu kadar basit.
(Alkış)
İkinci olarak.
İkinci olarak, bizim adil rekabet
kurallarını yerleştirmemiz lazım.
Şimdi bakın burada bir yarışma
yapsam, desem ki;
''10 kişiye New York Üniversitesi’nden
burs vereceğim ama yarışma adil olmayacak"
Katılır mısınız böyle bir yarışmaya?
Katılsanız çaba harcar mısınız?
Harcamazsınız.
Dünyada Daron Acemoğlu’nun da
ortaya koyduğu,
tarihsel olarak çok basit bir veri var.
Adalet sistemini oturtan
ülkeler ilerliyor.
Çünkü diyor ki oradaki yurttaş:
''Çok çalışırsam emeğimin hakkını alırım."
Rekabet adil olacak ve
herkes bu yarışa girecek.
Biz ne yapıyoruz?
Nüfusun yarısı kadınlar,
siz yarışa girmeyin.
Öbür yarısı ideolojik olarak
siz filan partidensiniz, almıyorum.
Geri kalanlar işte şu mezhep,
din, vesaire vesaire.
Nüfusunun %5’i ile üretim
yapan bir ülkeyiz biz.
Öbür tarafta %100’le giriyor Finlandiya.
Senden çok üretiyor, nasıl oluyor bu?
Son olarak, en önemlisi bu.
Bizim, bu hayal ekonomisine gitmemiz için
çocuklarımızın itiraz etmesi lazım.
Bunu da kim ölçüyor biliyor musunuz?
Bakın, OECD ölçüyor.
Bir ekonomik kuruluştur bu.
OECD, 15 yaşındaki çocukların,
‘’critical thinking and problem
solving’’ diye geçiyor bu.
Yani ben bunu Türkçe'ye "itiraz etme"
olarak çeviriyorum biraz kısa olsun diye.
''İtiraz etme becerisi.''
Türkiye’de bu oran %2,2.
15 yaşındaki çocuklarımızın
itiraz etme becerisi.
Güney Kore’de bu oran %28.
OECD ortalaması %11.
Şimdi bakın, normal koşullarda,
çocuklar zaten doğdukları zaman
%5'i üstün yetenekli.
Hiçbir şey yapmanıza gerek yok.
Biz o %5'i alıyoruz, 10 yıl eğitiyoruz ve
%2,2’ye kadar düşürüyoruz.
Bizim en büyük sıkıntımız bu:
İtiraz etmeyi bilmiyoruz.
Şimdi büyük bir sessizlik istiyorum,
belki de bütün bu anlattığımı
benden çok daha iyi anlatacak
bir şair abimizden bir mısra.
‘’Düşünde bile göremez işler,
düşlerin gördüğü işleri.’’
Düşünde bile göremez işler,
düşlerin gördüğü işleri.
İşte bu yüzden itiraz edin diyorum.
Bana itiraz edin.
Hocam bu konuşma iyi bir konuşma değil,
bu konuşma olmadı diye bana itiraz edin.
New York’tan bunun için mi
geldin diye itiraz edin.
İtiraz edin, bu çocuklar çok daha iyi
eğitilmeli diye itiraz edin.
En önemlisi bu ülke çok daha iyi
yönetilmeyi hak ediyor diye itiraz edin.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)